[Music]
you're watching swipe and here's a
little taste of what we've got for you
in the next 10 minutes Alex looks at the
not so secret life of pets with the tech
keeping tabs on what they're up to
meanwhile I'll be climbing inside the
chamber set to recharge my body and
we've got Vikings knights and samurais
in our games review
welcome to swipe we've come to a clinic
this week to see a unique kind of
treatment which is apparently being used
by sport stars celebrities and
biohackers to help rejuvenate their
bodies but before we talk more about
boosting human performance alex has been
looking at the animal kind or more
specifically the technology that we can
use to keep tabs on our pets health take
a look at this welcome to life as a dog
things appear very different on this end
of the lead so as pets own is it can be
hard to get a real sense of the health
and the well-being of our animals but
given the expansion in wearable health
tech for us it was only a matter of time
before the pet sector caught up so
Dexter's wearing one of the helix
devices and that measures that movement
of motion so it's collecting data from
all three axes X Y and Zed and we're
using that to kind of identify things
like walking running jumping a new
British startup has brought together
vets and engineers from companies like
Dyson to create what they call the first
smart pet health monitor and given the
global pet market is estimated to be
worth well over a hundred billion
dollars you can see the incentive to
pair our love of animals with our love
of tech this device is worn by the pets
and when the pet comes into proximity
with this beacon we get pairing so this
sends out a unique ID that says you've
paired with the factory ball and we
measure how long it simmer and the
frequency or frequency duration and from
that we can build up a pattern so that
data gets sent up to the cloud and then
we can manipulate data analyze it and
then feed that information back onto a
small phone and dinnertime proved the
perfect chance for us to put the
prototype to the test a simple glance of
the smartphone app lets us know that
Dexter has left the basket and has his
nose in a bowl so at the moment a lot of
what this technology can tell you is the
activity your pets up to their movement
around the house but as things evolve
and develop it'll be able to tell you
more about their health and well-being
because what a dog like Ziggy can't do
is tell you when you might need to go
and see the
et I've got away with it
so as this tech starts to influence the
way we care for our animals what a vet's
make of it there is nothing as good as
having the personal relationship with
your pet and that includes the
relationship with the vet so it's that
sort of triangle of information of pet
owner the technology where it's
appropriate and the veterinary
relationship but we must never use these
devices as a substitute for
understanding our animals as devices
become smaller and smarter I expect
we'll be seeing much more from the pet
sector and future so a secret life of
pets might not be such a secret alex
morgan skye stay with us in a couple of
minutes i'll be climbing inside a
chamber to bathe my body in oxygen from
the inside out thank you
that's coming right up after a roundup
of this week's tech news Google has
overtaken Apple as the world's most
valuable brand Global 500 rankings show
the search engine in the top spot
despite Apple's iPhone sales returning
to growth at the end of last year
apparently the study looks at the future
of a company rather than its past this
bot might soon be picking your shopping
Accardo the online grocery retailer has
been working with some European
universities on a robotic arm that can
grasp products in its warehouses without
damaging them we heard about the death
of 91 year old Messiah Nakamura this
week also known as the father of pac-man
he founded Namco which released the game
Guinness World Records named it the
world's most successful coin-operated
arcade game and in Italy virtual
realities letting visitors look around
the golden palace that belonged to Roman
Emperor and narrow
apparently narrow would have loved the
VR experience he was said to be a tech
enthusiast although a brutal leader
stick around for our games review if
you're a fan of Dark Souls you'll want
to hear about neo
but before that now this is a hyperbaric
oxygen chamber apparently used by sports
stars celebrities and biohackers for a
number of reasons of which we're gonna
find out more right now because Tim is
here
Tim you own this and it's time I had a
go today so what do I need to know you
need to get in you need to enjoy
yourself for an hour just by relaxing
meditating letting the oxygen do its
thing so this is your oxygen mask so we
can give you oxygen ninety seven percent
roughly so so there is an oxygen in the
tank that's right yeah I mean you can't
breathe without it but this is where we
give you the ninety seven percent oxygen
[Music]
tim's colleague hyperbaric medicine
expert dr. robert Pender sets the
machine while I try to relax well until
I start to feel the effects of the air
pressure luckily dr. Pender can talk to
me by speakerphone I won't lie it did
feel a little scary at first but anyway
about the therapy
[Music]
be able to absorb so it helps your body
flourish rare isn't it very well let me
ask anybody because the medical
profession is more geared up to
pharmaceuticals you can't patent oxygen
also it's it's growing
medicine right now referrals from the
NHS now and the world is spreading I
mean a lot of people have been using it
for many many
there's gotta be a powerful without
oxygen program because administering
oxygen under pressure means that we also
do
great to Neverland you could do that
normal star in Prussia
that was a really weird experience I
feel a bit lightheaded I'm a bit drowsy
is that normal sharp electron thank you
very much bye-bye now while I adjust to
plain old regular air again I'm gonna
hand you over to Luke with our games
review and mind out because there's a
fair bit of fighting this week piranhor
is an action hack and slash game from
Ubisoft in which you choose between one
of three factions representing Knights
samurai or Viking the aim of the game is
really focused upon its combat so you'll
be running around a map taking out lots
of lower-level kind of foes but
eventually when it really gets
interesting is when you bump into
another player controlled or a I control
character who's a bit stronger and
that's when the tactical combat system
hack-and-slash usually implies that it's
quite rushed quite frantic that this is
a very very weighty and intelligent take
on a genre definitely one you should
notice halo was - is a real-time
strategy game a bit like command &
Conquer but set in the world of Halo the
original Halo Wars came out eight years
ago but the event of this game take
place after halo 5 guardians while a
campaign is very robust the main joy
here is to be found in the multiplayer
where there are a huge variety of modes
that will appeal to old hands at RTS
games but also to newcomers which is
really really important because this is
quite an accessible game for fans of the
Halo franchise taking control of units
that you've seen many many times before
and unleashing key ability is a real
thrill that as I say is still accessible
the newcomers which i think is very
important neo is an action RPG that has
drawn quite a lot of comparisons with
the Dark Souls series and for good
reason because the developer has
actually admitted it was a big big
inspiration my experience was that the
combat is slightly more complex than it
is in Dark Souls simply because of both
pacing but also in terms the number of
stances and abilities that you have to
juggle one of the main draws of the Dark
Souls series is this big interconnected
world that you're traversing and it
really creates a sense of atmosphere in
neo you have individual levels which
some of them do bear the shortcuts and
all the hallmarks that you see in souls
but it's not as commonplace that said
the upside of this means that once
you've completed a level you can go back
and play it again as a twilight mission
which is much much harder and something
I would not recommend if you have
but despite that if you are looking for
something to scratch that Souls itch
this is definitely the best tribute out
there
well that's it for this week but don't
forget to follow us on Twitter
ask I new swipe and you can see what we
get up to throughout the week I'll be
back next time hope you can join us
there bye bye
[Music]